welcome to this video playing yeah but
once again hadn't played him for quite a
while and let's look at the statistics
not not great four out of 11 he was a
good player of course it wasn't so sure
about the statistics um Jade Ross
absolutely no draw so the the same ish
let's see what he's doing against it
playing them with a closed center here
not a line that I have a high regard
high regard of I think while it's just
better in this structure especially I
mean in this concrete case where he has
already castle on it it's a difference
if black has not cashed out really
because then you can also sometimes get
the King to the Queen side here it's not
really helpful to have the kingdom I
have not cancelled and i will push with
g4 probably okay let's see i can i can
first play those type of strengthening
moves and then see if i can really push
with h 4g form the question is how to
start with g4 or h5 I go g4 there might
be night h form
interesting i think i prefer to to start
with h4 h4 night h5 could be an idea I
have Bishop g5 them okay it's not really
really helping him Wow where are you
going where are you going with that okay
maybe Knight b6 Bishop b3 try to attack
c4 in that way pool well it's creative
its creative but still I cannot believe
it it's doing those kind of fancy
maneuvers value while you are pushed
back on the King side like that okay he
wants to play B 5 p.m. how to how to
play that no G 32 f five years this is
certainly right b6 Wow not be five and
maybe this was also slip up some some
sorts okay and let's see now g6 is the
normal way really to to break it open I
wonder i still wonder g6 or i want to
have this routine to play the a1 look
must play as well king of two blocks the
second rank and it's not so great
maybe this first and intention intending
g6 well this looks pretty good ok and
now now go g6 okay boys this is this too
too too quick and away okay okay this
must this must be a good good move I
really I really cannot believe you
cannot believe that it should be a
mistake g6 what am i threatening
actually maybe to take and rook g12 ok
here i can take on age 7 I think I
should check g1 it probably won't take
but I have a direct attack on g7 which
you cannot cover really g1 or queen g3
Qantas better it's both pretty good
maybe this one hook a 22 g to get this
rook into the play can I sacrifice the
three with rock g2 and I can take root
g7 and queens III sss winning okay now i
need to take I guess
and now let's see how is this how should
this beam be one now Queen h6 intending
to take on g6 and should g5 at the end
how this looks it looks devastating rock
g6 takes Queen g6 King edge 8 and Bishop
g5 intending I don't even need that
sorry I don't even eat yet I can I can
play it simpler um okay group g7 no
black resign yeah look look g7 I mean
maybe I ever have something but better
even the drug which is seven is enough
yeah this was just too bad the sir this
is this position and so this general
structure here is already a bit tricky
and he lost lots of time in addition
with Bishop a foreign those kind of
maneuvers it just it just does not look
right yeah well here I cannot believe in
this position at all with good play why
should really win this it's it's too
much too much stuff on the king and b6
was probably some sort of mouse live I
mean there's no reason not to play b5 it
was the original intention and he played
b5 just some goofs later and after g6
its bastard yeah plus five computers
pretty drastic here check digs and which
I just I just want to check your firm I
missed anything rook H or the computer
even gives locate us the best that's
nice I thought it just is just from a
logical point of you good to get every
piece involved but maybe something like
that is also winning edge
Plus for him okay it just made sense to
me get every piece into the game and TM
computer wants to take on CF right now
now I'd recognize that this wins Bishop
age six is winning okay but this also
right oh it sports a bit of the
advantage but still plus 5 and here the
chances of force made yeah this is what
I had calculated and okay I didn't sorry
my original idea was this which in fact
does win but then i saw that i can't i
can do that which also leads to a mate
but this is checkmate in quicker pointed
out by the engine yeah I don't three
think that this is a one hundred percent
sound way to battle the sameish it's a
bit too passive you can do that I think
if you have not castle this is at least
a playable line okay thanks for watching